euh Bruno Daru très très bien accueilli
par le par les parlementaires
britanniques il a été ovationné le
président zenki un réel engagement
une invasion qu'on avait pas eu sans
doute depuis le président Nelson Mandela
ici dans ce hall de Westminster mais
vous l'avez dit Bruno l'a dit avec un
message clé la clé de voûte de se
déplacement ici la clé de vote sans
doute du déplacement qui suivra à
Bruxelles
le président zenenski veut repousser les
limites cette aide militaire donnée par
les pays de l'OTAN en particulier à
l'Ukraine et donc avec son message nous
avons la liberté donnez-nous des ailes
pour la protéger bien sûr il a rallié
dans son camp le Premier ministre
richissounac qui a annoncé aujourd'hui
même qu'il y avait un début de formation
de pilote de chasse
ukrainien ici autour de Solsbury dans
dans le sud de l'Angleterre ils vont cet
après-midi le Président zellenski le
premier ministre rushisounac allait voir
ses formations les formations de de pil
est également en information de marine
et bien sûr les formations au char
d'assaut challenger 2 qui partiront
bientôt vers l'Ukraine qui doivent être
en place à la fin du mois de mars avec
également des canons de 155 mm une
quarantaine de canon 255 mm à 90 ce qui
est très important puisque ils sont
capables de tirer à 40 km c'est canon là
et bien sûr l'Ukraine en a besoin bien
sûr est-ce que la question que tout le
monde se pose il y avait répondu à
quelques jours et chez sunnac que la
porte n'était pas encore ouverte à la
livraison d'avions de chasse à l'Ukraine
mais aujourd'hui une page a été tournée
on ne personne ne s'attend à ce qu'il y
a une annonce de livraison de d'avions
aujourd'hui Régis Jonak probablement ne
ne parle ne le dira pas de cette façon
mais il dit déjà ouvertement qu'il se
prépare sur le long terme à soutenir
avec des avions de chasse l'Ukraine donc
il y aura sans doute une discussion qui
aura entre les alliés sur ce point mais
véritablement c'est le cœur du débat ici
c'est le message central de ce
déplacement il est venu mettre la
pression le président zenenski sur tous
les alliés européens en particulier pour
qu'on ouvre une nouvelle page de d'aide
à l'Ukraine c'est ce que dès le début de
l'invasion le 24 février il attendait
c'est-à-dire pouvoir avoir le contrôle
du ciel ukrainien merci beaucoup Hervé à